Speaker 1: So last week, after we learned of
the imminent overturning of Roe v Wade by the
Supreme Court, thanks to thanks to this leaked
decision, we still don't know who leaked it. And
we'll talk about that later. One of the things
I and some others said is they're not going to
stop at just abortion. You don't stop after your
biggest victory, arguably in decades. You say,
What else can I get? You've gotten an inch. So you
try to take a mile. Really, you've gotten a mile.
So you try to take ten miles. And some of you
wrote to me and said, David, I just don't see it.
I was confronted by some callers last week saying,
David, this isn't going to happen. And as I said
last week, I don't literally believe that they're
going to try to ban interracial marriage anytime
soon. I mentioned a number of different areas
that they might focus contraception, gay marriage,
all these other things. And sure, there are people
who are against abortion who also happen to be
against interracial marriage. We know that
because we just know about demographics and
and statistics in the United States. And over the
weekend, in just a two day period, we are already
seeing them push beyond this in two different
cases. Let's look at each of these examples,
first and foremost. Jake TAPPER on CNN
interviewed Mississippi Governor Tate Reeves,
which Tate Reeves and Mississippi are at the
core of this antiabortion push. Mississippi
passing one of the most, if not the most
restrictive abortion bill in the country,
which is now the subject and the appeal matter for
the Supreme Court in the decision that will likely
overturn Roe v Wade. And Jake TAPPER asked
Tate Reeves, okay, well, what about banning
plan B, sometimes known as the morning after pill?
What about banning IUDs? These are intrauterine
devices. It's a form of birth control that is
available to people if they prefer that over the
pill or whatever else. Are you going to push for
that? And Tate Reeves doesn't say, no, we're not
interested in that. Tate Reeves very coyly, says
we're not focused on that right now, which means
we're leaving the door open to do exactly that.
Speaker 2: What we have is a leaked draft.
Speaker 3: We don't have a final. Yeah, no, I
agree. I, I agree on the matter. But just to be
clear, the state of Mississippi, you're not going
to then target IUD or plan B, which are methods
of birth control that might not allow a fertilized
egg to be implanted. And this is not a theoretical
construct. This is not, you know, the state of
Louisiana, which I recognize is a neighboring
state, not your state. I mean, they're
talking about not only criminally charging
girls and women who get abortions, as, you know,
as as being committing homicide. But they're also
talking about defining the moment of conception
as fertilization, which would theoretically,
if this were to become the law of Louisiana. And
it is not yet. I mean, that murder, if you use an
IUD, you're committing murder theoretically. So
it's not I'm not making this up. This is these
are the conversations going on in legislatures
in your in your area. But so just to be clear,
you have no intention of seeking to ban
IUDs or plan B. But that is not what we
are focused on at this time. We're focused on.
Speaker 1: That is not. So the question was,
you have no plan to ban these things. And he says
that is not what we are focused on at this time.
We know enough about how politicians speak, that
we can understand what that means. And then Texas
Governor Greg Abbott, he's also reinvigorated
and full of energy for banning more things on
the news of this Roe v Wade decision, forthcoming
decision. He says, well, listen, now that we we've
gotten this Roe v Wade thing, we are going to look
at challenging a Supreme Court ruling as well,
which protects the right to free public education
for every kid, including kids with undocumented
parents. Right now, if you're a kid and your
parents are undocumented, so the Supreme Court
has decided you still have access to public
schooling. Supreme Court decision. Greg Abbott
says we're going to look at overturning that.
Speaker 2: No, this and that is Texas already
long ago sued the federal government about having
to incur the cost of their education program. Yes,
it's a case called Plyler versus Doe.
And the Supreme Court ruled against us
on the issue about denying or, let's say, Texas
having to bear that burden. I think we will
resurrect that case and challenge this issue
again, because the expenses are extraordinary.
Speaker 1: There it is. I mean,
they are invigorated and rightly so.
Plan B and IUDs could be next in Mississippi.
Taking away schooling from the children of
undocumented immigrants is on the agenda in Texas
and they are rightly invigorated. Again, this. I
would if I were them and I just got arguably one
of the biggest political victories in decades,
I would be feeling pretty damn invigorated as
well, and I'd be saying, Well, what else we
can do? What else can we do? Where else can
we go with this? And they are going places.
Interracial marriage. Yeah, maybe not. Maybe
not. But these are areas they are definitely
going dangerous times. We have Memorial Day coming
up on Monday, Memorial Day, May 30. We are going
to be running a blowout membership special that
is going to absolutely rock your socks off. Knock
your socks off. Wow. Smack your socks up. I don't
even know. I'm so fired up by it and it's going to
be fantastic. Alex Jones is furious about it.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Incredible. If you want
to take advantage of this historic
membership discount to really get us ready for
the midterms, please sign up for my newsletter at
David Pakman dot com. And on Monday, Memorial Day,
you'll get an email telling you how to sign up.